Easy Money Baby easy money
he's
elevated dread
oh is that the
scp-087 no that's SCP Containment Breach
I know that anywhere
yeah
that's the one
yes wow it's been a long and rough day
but finally this is the last house I
just need to put up remaining flyers on
every apartment's door that's annoying
and that is it I will get my first
salary
wow I need glasses I can't see stuff I
don't need glasses anymore because I
have perfect vision I have 2015 Vision
are you jealous you should be my God my
eyes are amazing they're perfect in
every way and you wish you had perfect
eyes like me proceed to interact
missing have you seen
be aware when coming in he is following
you
[Music]
you can enter any three-digit department
number I'll let you in
[Music]
I don't know how that worked I don't
know how that managed to get ever do I
have a it's oh
we
well I didn't it's not called
sterilevated dreads so I'm gonna go take
the elevator because I ain't no [__]
I ain't no baby
I can't see [__]
putting up a flyer Wham Halloween party
oh cool oh sweet maybe this isn't so bad
after all I thought it was going to be
like selling something no this is for
this is for people's enjoyment
Halloween party everybody get ready for
fun fun fun fun fun fun
oh shoot dang
you know how it'd be it's dark
God damn it's dark
well I'm gonna do my job right I'm gonna
put up these flyers
um yeah you bet you're
sweet ass
you bet you're
sweet ass you bet your my sweet ass
pills you know how it's gonna be
yeah can I get in the elevator
I'll press two
there's a lot of floors
[Music]
oh look at the art is
beautiful
oh
[Music]
oh hi hi hi
why do I need hide
why do I need to hide
I'm just trying to tell people about a
Halloween party
it's for it's for everyone's good
everyone's going to be real happy about
it
oh oh
do I really got to do this for every
floor
the seems rather tedious
okay
this is going great I feel good about my
prospects and my choice of career
uh-huh
wait
oh my God oh my God it was in there it
couldn't be someone living here
foreign
just
someone going home
it was probably just someone going to
their apartment
where they live
because why not
foreign
don't know what that's about but it's
not my problem
none of this is my problem
oh
foreign
[Music]
huh
I'm not getting out yes it was on level
two
but it was walking towards the stairs
which meant that it could have been
going to level three which is where I
was
and you know what
I'm not about that
I ain't about that oh
orange
sassafras why would I turn that off
I can only assume it went down to level
one or something I don't know
I don't care don't know no no don't care
oh no don't care oh good
great
because I go up
foreign
stay
oh oh my God
[Music]
that's all that matters that's all that
matters oh nice painting oh wait no it's
not it's horrible
foreign
blood
[Music]
oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy
what
okay oh boy oh boy
[__] I can't see [__]
oh boy
I'm going in here oh where am I
you're mining sorry I'm in your closet
now
what is that oh man I am not about this
guys I'm not about this I don't like
this
I don't need this job I don't want this
job I'm I'm not about this all right
whatever
do I put it on the door in here what's
the deal
there's no door in here
what am I looking at what okay that's
fun
well I don't know why I came in here I
feel what is wrong with you
stop stop stop stop stop with that you
stop with that right now I'm gonna go
I'm here now
God I thought it would yeah
oh my God
[Music]
oh God
yeah foreign
everybody
put up the Flyers
easy peasy job well done get paid for
the Flyers get paid make money I like
money I lock money
is a good a reason to do [__] like this
I like money
I love money
I want more money
better give me some money
I'm gonna need some money
all right only a few more flaws to go
almost done easy easy as pie easy as can
be easy ah
[Music]
thank you
why'd the singing stop
[Music]
they look at the sky it's going to be a
fine night tonight it's going to be
[Music]
fine
what a Bop
that's that's my jam
lost my jam right there
hey look at the grass
[Music]
I love this song
I love this I love everything about this
I love all of this this is the grill
I'm not ready
[Music]
I'm leaving
Windows they leave the house
[Music]
yep yep nothing to worry about nothing
to worry about just get the job done
just just get the job done oh that's
fine that's fine it's going to be a fine
day for this Halloween party I open the
windows to look at the grass
there's two more floors there's two more
floors and then I'm done then I'm out
now ow
ow
easy easy money easy money money
[Music]
Easy Money easy money
wait wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute I really need glasses because if
I Didn't Know Better
If I Didn't Know Better
if I if I
If I Didn't Know Better yeah
you wanna go
ha ha
huh
okay okay
I'm gonna go in that room
I'm gonna go in that room I'm gonna go
in there I'm gonna go in there and I'm
gonna see what's going on I'm going in
there I'm going in three two one
recorded I'm going in that room three
two
Halloween party
Halloween
[Music]
it's fine
it's fine it's fine
it's what everything's fine tomato soup
great it's just tomato soup everybody
it's not blood it's tomato soup
oh you want to go to Halloween party
[Applause]
Easy Money
Easy Money Easy Money Easy Money easy
money they go on though easy
[Music]
easy money
Easy Money Baby
easy money I gotta remember I didn't put
a
[Music]
I didn't put the uh flyer in this wall
all right easy
[Music]
Easy Money Baby
Easy Money flies on some doors Halloween
party
easy money
oh man look at it
[Applause]
I don't want to watch that I don't I
don't want to watch that
um well I guess my job's done there's no
doors on this level
easy money
foreign
[Music]
easy money
we go home we go home baby we go home
we're home free
Easy Money
easy money
God damn that was nothing
[Music]
get my first paycheck
oh
it's gone
[Music]
oh
like this
[Music]
no don't do it don't do it don't do it
no dude
don't do it stop
stop
[Music]
oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh
Easy Money Baby easy money
these
oh raise your money
good game
good game good game good game
okay I go
clean something out of my pants it seems
to be a bit of a Calamity occurred so I
guess I gotta take care of that
[Music]